a trailer for series three of picard has
dropped already halfway through series
two of picard but why
is there a reason why they've dropped it
now
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so if you haven't seen it the advert for
card series three's dropped and it seems
like the whole crew are getting back
together except one person but we'll
talk about that in a minute
i think back on those days on the
enterprise and all that danger we rushed
into
everybody from tng is coming back gates
mcfadden is coming back as beverly
crusher will she try and sleep with any
more ghosts we just don't know john luke
when the galaxy comes calling you love
it
marina surges is coming back is diana
troy
everybody is coming back obviously brent
spiner will be back and jonathan franks
as well
as well as
somebody is taking a break from their
game show hosting roles and popular
podcasts as jodie laforge is also going
to be making a return
so
i gotta admit i am really excited by
this
every single time i think i'm about to
give up on star trek and that i've had
enough i watch another discovery episode
or something i think no no more star
trek they draw me back in
picard series one particularly the end i
hated it
after many videos i've told you
repeatedly how much i dislike it and for
many many reasons but then picard series
two started and they fixed so many of
the problems even though
it's gone a little bit downhill for me
since the first episode but hey i'm
hoping for a big finale and then the
strange new world trailers drop and i'm
gonna do a video on that very shortly
but oh my god it looks freaking amazing
and the picard series 3 trailer has done
it again it's got the comms badge the
original going
it is clear sacrifice is required again
it goes and answers it and we see a
little bit with him and jonathan frakes
and we hear a lot of the voices
including wharf
so you know even michael dawn is making
a return it looks really really exciting
i love that they're filming these back
to back but why drop the trailer
mid-season
the marketing people get to decide these
things it seems like a strange decision
to me
the mid-season
maybe it's just to give picard season
two a bit of a bump get people excited
get people talking a lot of clicks well
it worked people have gone nuts over
this i've seen several articles on
screen rants etc etc about the whole
cast coming back together if they needed
just a little bump just card series 2 it
will have worked
but is picard series 2 really doing that
badly that it needed a bit of a bump
wouldn't the advert for picard series 3
been a good idea to drop at the very end
marvel style mid credits people would
have lost their freaking minds
but maybe they didn't do that because
they've got something else planned for
the end of picard series 2.
if pecan series 2 is going to get a
spin-off series wouldn't that be a good
idea to drop at the end of series 2. so
now this is complete speculation but
there are several ways you could spin
off from picard and let's be honest in
this time frame the picard series
they're not just gonna leave it there so
what could they do
they could see a stargazer series now
that would be really cool i actually
really like captain rios i love the
actor i think he's great in most things
i see him in
[Music]
it looks wicked they put loads of really
good designs into it they've teased us
with little things like using borg
technology what the hell does that mean
and you know it that could be a really
cool series
so that's one possibility
could we see the long envisaged michael
dawn has been desperate for years wolf
series he's been quite open about really
desperately wanting a wolf series
apparently there was a pilot written at
some point and you know maybe we see a
bit more about what wharf is doing now
i don't know maybe
it's a possibility
talking about warfare
what are they going to do with the
klingon
surely that's a little bit of a problem
of course for themselves thanks to
discovery and jj abrams you utter how
are they going to actually sort out the
war problem because they
are just going to keep them the same are
they going to change they're going to
try and do something that's halfway in
between because if they do
people are not going to be happy
so anyway that's a possibility
could we see a seven of nine and arrange
a spin-off series they seem to tease it
once or twice throughout the first
series that there's this whole mythos
they could explore so again maybe that's
a possibility we know that dr beverly
crusher stayed in starfleet we saw it in
the last couple of episodes of star trek
the next generation still a captain
aboard the pasteur maybe we see a uh
doctors in space
i'm joking with that one please god
kurtzman don't make that that would be
awful please don't do that but let's
very quickly talk about the elephant in
the room because somebody
is missing from the lineup sir
i know this may finish me as an acting
ensign but shut up wesley
there will be no wesley crusher chef
wesley he won't be in the series
he has come out in public said some
people have said they're always a bit of
a trick is they're doing a marvel on us
are they going to zig and then zagging
is really going to be in it at the end
somewhere
well no i don't think they will and to
be honest will wheaton seem to quite
resign to the fact he has actually
produced some fan fiction please go over
to the scitrek facebook group um the
link for it is there there's a link for
the facebook group in the description
the problem with bringing wesley shut up
wesley
is that
he's become a traveler now the way he
left the series was kind of cheesy and
no one liked it so
who are you
[Music]
the traveler
i've waited a long time for this moment
wesley so
writing him back into the series would
actually be a little bit difficult he's
basically a god of sorts and you know
bringing him back into the series i
think would be very difficult and not to
make it cheesy so
you know i think that's the main reason
why he's been left out because his story
arc ended he left to become a traveler
and we're never going to see him again
and to be honest i don't want him
because i love will wheaton
i hate wesley
he was a weezy little character and i
don't ever want to see him back on our
screens again guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think why did they
drop this trailer when they did and what
did you think of the trailer are you
excited about this is star trek drawing
you back in like it's drawing me back in
get to the comments tell me exactly what
you think and if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification it really helps us out
and consider joining the channel and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
hit the join button as always guys
please stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you